russ
congratulations on that victory if you
can just
walk us through that sequence when brad
hit the three
garrison gets the steal you hit the
three what was going through all your
minds
just win right now all that matters is
that we get a win and uh we
we fought through tonight man there's so
much ups and downs in our team right now
and tonight
we gotta win that's all that matters and
uh you know i'm proud of everybody in
the locker room
uh speaking of being proud i think we're
proud of you the way you was attacking
the basket tonight with that authority
and that aggressiveness tell me what has
changed
over the last week with you and your
help well i got healthy yeah exactly
exactly you know my legs feel a lot
better man i was
you know out there playing one leg and
just trying to give everything i had and
try to take a little break but
you know like every other game every
night man i give all the glory to the
men above for
allowing me to go out and better compete
and um thank you to be to do that
well russell westbrook 41 points tonight
including that game-winning three
it was a heck of a comeback you guys
were down by 18 in the first quarter and
won it congratulations thanks for
joining us
good job tonight